so the Democratic Party moving forward
with impeachment spread the fact they
don't seem to have any hard evidence of
a crime being committed that ain't
stoppin the House Intelligence Committee
which brought forth a bunch of
democratic lawyers to testify shockingly
enough they don't like President Trump
and want to see him impeach joining us
on the line to discuss is Jenna Ellis
she's a constitutional law attorney and
senior legal adviser for the Trump
twenty20 campaign she's also the author
of the legal basis for a moral
Constitution and a fellow at the Falkirk
Center at Liberty University Jenna
thanks so much for joining the show
thanks so much for having me Ben so
Jenna you've been watching some of these
hearings moving forward I'm not sure
what Democrats actually think they are
accomplishing with these hearings maybe
they don't think they're accomplishing
anything which is why they're moving so
quickly is it because they do not have
the goods they are moving this fast yeah
you know I think they're definitely just
wanting to pull the wool over the
American public and I have a piece out
actually in Town Hall this morning
that's called the headline is House
Judiciary from bombshell the Democrats
are trying to change the Constitution I
don't know if you read the House
Judiciary report that came out Saturday
then but it was shocking to me that the
Democrats actually admitted two things
first they said that they are actually
going to change the standard of
impeachment and no longer was the
standard from Nixon and Clinton era good
enough because of course they don't have
a constitutional or legal basis for
Trump and second that impeachment is not
just to punish past wrongdoing but to
protect the nation from future threats
to democracy so they're actually
admitting in their report that this is a
completely baseless unconstitutional
impeachment they are simply wanting to
in their view protect the nation from
reelecting president Trump in 2020
that's all this is about it's because
they know they can't win the election no
Jenna this is the thing that is stunned
to me I spoke about it a little bit
earlier on the show today the the open
acknowledgement by Jerry Nadler that the
entire basis for the impeachment effort
is to quote unquote prevent corruption
in twenty twenty election Democrats have
not accepted the results of a national
election in which Republicans have won
since about 1988 they think that Gore
won in 2000 they think that because Gore
won in 2000 2004 is illegitimate they
think that Trump lost in 2016 and now
they're pushing forward with this line
that frump is not impeached then if he
wins in 2020 then it is fundamentally
alleged
that he has somehow cheated in order to
win in 2020 so they're actually
presetting the narrative that if Trump
wins he's not a legitimate president
again in 2020 I mean there's a natural
danger to the country in this absolutely
and they've been pushing that narrative
since the 2016 election and they've been
trying to undermine the legitimacy of
the first four years of the term
administration and you're exactly right
that's what they're going to be doing in
2020 and let's also forget them they
don't have a candidate right now they
don't have a real frontrunner they don't
have a lot of money either and so this
is using taxpayer dollars to actually
put forth their narrative through the
Congress that they're getting
essentially free campaigning and free
advertising on mainstream media networks
for hours and hours and hours that's not
here in my adoption and that is
fundamentally wrong and against all
notions of fundamental fairness and
actually they're trying to election air
that in so many different ways and it's
completely illegitimate so general what
do you think
the rest of this process looks like
Democrats are talking of course about
doing some sort of house impeachment
vote before Christmas I'd be shocked if
they don't considering that again
they're not waiting around to even talk
to the people who talk to Trump I mean
this is the dead giveaway they don't
have the goods if they really believe
they had the goods they'd have no fear
of waiting for the subpoenas for
Giuliani or bulton to be adjudicated by
courts but they're not actually waiting
for any of that they said we don't even
need those facts we have enough to go on
which is a lie I mean they don't have
enough to go on so it looks like they're
gonna move forward quickly and then this
thing goes to the Senate what do you
think the process ends up looking like
if the Senate yeah and you know I think
it was also really interesting as well
then that Adam Schiff who had this whole
report front intelligences Intelligence
Committee didn't show up to present his
report why is that well because he would
have to go under up and he is very very
concerned about that that is a dead
giveaway as well and so the Democrats
are just pushing this forward if they
end up going to a vote and if Nancy
Pelosi really thinks that she can get
articles of impeachment I've voted on
and passed then if this goes to the
Senate I think it's dead on arrival I
mean Ted Cruz came out so strongly over
this past weekend talking about that
Lindsey Graham other people who actually
are recognizing that there is
fundamental fairness there is a
constitutional element of due process
here a trial in the Senate
would absolutely expose the Democrats
for this hypocrisy and I think would
actually be very very unfortunate for
them because you would have so many of
the witnesses they don't want called you
would have Adam Schiff you would have
Joe Biden you'd have hunter bright you'd
have the whole context of this whole
scam and so I think it will be very
interesting to see whether or not this
does actually preceded us on it because
that is not going to be good for the
Democrats whatsoever especially because
several of the key candidates who are
senators will then be tied up in when
there are key carcasses going on like
Iowa and headed into early next year
they're going to be tied up in the
Senate and campaign so this is just the
Democrats completely losing on every
single strategy that they might put
forward so I think it will be
interesting to see if they actually move
this forward or end up somehow dropping
it in a way that they think might be
favorable to them